[Música]
y en directo a vamos hasta brasil porque
faltan menos de 50 días para las
elecciones presidenciales y la campaña
de los principales candidatos empezó con
fuerza tanto el presidente ya er
bolsonaro como el ex mandatario luiz
inácio lula da silva llevaron a cabo
eventos masivos en los que se agredieron
mutuamente para ampliar la noticia
conectamos hasta ahora con nuestro
corresponsal en río de janeiro pierde 2
pierre muy buenas noches cuéntenos cómo
transcurrió el primer día oficial de
campañas
los dos grandes favoritos hicieron sus
primeros actos de campaña en lugares muy
simbólicos para ambos bolsonaro hizo su
primer discurso en la vía peatonal de la
ciudad de ruiz de fuera donde fue
apuñalado hace cuatro años a un poco
menos de un mes de la primera vuelta de
las elecciones un ataque que contribuyó
a funcionar lo en las encuestas tomó un
tono muy religioso diciendo que era el
lugar donde renació gracias a la mano de
dios' y dijo también que el bien iba a
vencer contra el mal su principal
adversario lula da silva hizo su primer
acto a las puertas de una fábrica
volkswagen en san bernardo del campo
donde empezó su carrera política como
líder es sindical
también hizo un discurso muy fuerte nada
veloz dijo que bolsonaro es poseído por
el demonio y también que intenta
manipular a los evangélicos después de
estos actos
ex presidente y el actual mandatario
participaron en la investidura del
presidente del tribunal superior
electoral quien será de cierta forma el
árbitro de esta campaña y de estas
elecciones
bien era pierre la edad nuestro
corresponsal en río de janeiro muchas
gracias por este reporte sobre las
elecciones presidenciales